mr president
excellencies
i want to reaffirm
what i expressed this morning
in the meeting of the general assembly
but of course it wouldn't make any sense
to bother you
reading again the same texts
that i'm sure you are all aware of
in between during the day
a number of events took place
and with your permission mr president
i would like to ask miss rosemary
dicarlo
to be able to brief you on those events
but simultaneously
the day was full of rumors
and indications
that
a
of an offensive
against the ukraine
was
imminent
in the recent past there were several
situations
with similar
indications
similar rumors
and i never believed in them
convinced that nothing serious
would happen
i was wrong
and i would like not to be wrong again
today
so
if indeed
an operation is being prepared
i have only one thing to say
from the bottom of my heart
president putin
stop your troops from attacking the
ukraine
give peace a chance
too many people have already died